hallo meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem weiteren video
auf meinem kanal und zwar ihr seht schon
wahrscheinlich im titel das ist hightech
und ich rede mal wieder über den thema
was mir so ein bisschen am herzen liegt
und zwar ich denke jeder mitbekommen
erst mal vorab ich produziere vor ich
drehe dieses video gerade am dienstag
geht's heute und ganz einfach weil ich
über das wochenende weg bin fünf tage
mit meiner familie mal ein bisschen
urlaub machen und so ostern und so also
ostern ssv später aber darum geht es gar
nicht deswegen wollte ich halt nur sagen
dass meine information eventuell nicht
auf dem neuesten stand sind also es kann
sein dass wenn ihr dieses video seht das
schon längst draußen ist weswegen das
flugzeug abgestürzt ist und so weiter
und so fort
und da bitte ich euch einfach dann mit
mir dafür schonend umzugehen weil ich
das video dementsprechend jetzt gerade
aufnehmen an dem tag wo es auch passiert
ist und zwar geht es wie viel grad schon
angedeutet habe um den flugzeugabsturz
von dem airbus a 320 war es meine ich
von germanwings von barcelona nach
düsseldorf und zwar ist dieser flieger
halt morgens von düsseldorf nach
barcelona geflogen und dann ist er
mittags meine ich wieder zurück geflogen
von barcelona nach düsseldorf und dort
ist er in südfrankreich über den alpen
in der nähe von einer kleinen stadt in
den bergen abgestürzt also das erstmal
jetzt so grob zu den informationen über
diese ganze sache falls es jemand nicht
mitgekriegt hat ich finde es traurig
wenn es jemand nicht mitbekommen hat er
freunde jetzt mal da vorne steht kratz
und ca aber das sieht schon echt
gewaltig aus hier also ein bisschen beim
gameplay muss man ja schon noch bleiben
auch wenn ich jetzt was ernstes spreche
aber das sieht ja schon sehr sehr
gewaltig aus dieses gebäude hier und
zwar ja ich finde es traurig wenn es
jemand nicht mitbekommen hat aber es
gibt natürlich leute die einfach nie
eine zeitung gucken oder nie auf n-tv
gehen oder neben tagesschau schauen oder
vielleicht auch sogar gerade im urlaub
sind und deswegen nicht ins internet
gehen können oder nichts mitbekommen
aber das erstmal zu groben sache also es
ist ein flugzeug abgestürzt da kann kann
ich jetzt natürlich mit einem video
nichts bewegen und ich kann doch jetzt
nicht die angehörigen der opfer also
sind eigentlich zu meiner erkenntnis
jetzt gerade es war halt gerade diese
pressekonferenz da es sind alle tot alle
leute die in dem flugzeug waren also es
waren meine ich 140 150 leute dort drin
passagiere und halt dann auch noch pilot
copilot und ganz normal euro jetzt hat
er mich gesehen jetzt hatte ich hatte
mich hat er mich er hat mich nicht
gesehen okay war sie ihre pilot copilot
und halt auch noch die ganz normalen
besatzungsmitglieder wie stewardess und
so weiter und so fort und halt auch ganz
normal wirklich die komplette maschine
und alles gepäck und so alles zerstört
oder die besatzung gestorben ich weiß
nicht ob ich jetzt gerade die passenden
worte dazu finde es ist auf jeden fall
eine extreme tragödie allerdings möchte
ich darüber nicht sogar sprechen weil
das ist halt einfach in unglück was
passiert ist es somit das größte
flugunglück für europa in den letzten
jahren und ich finde es traurig als ich
das gelesen habe morgens in der uni ich
saß da um 10 uhr dann war er einfach kam
diese nachricht rein da waren wir schon
alles so ein bisschen wie kann so etwas
passieren so bei der ganzen technik ich
weiß zu dem zeitpunkt also zu dem
zeitpunkt jetzt gerade weiß ich noch
nicht beziehungsweise weist man
allgemein noch nicht glaube ich woran es
genau gelegen hat ob es jetzt terror ist
es meine ich nicht das wurde schon
gesagt das ist dass das wurde schon
benannt auf jeden fall hinein gibt es
das wort benannt überhaupt kommen
einander nein jetzt packe ich hier nimmt
ich hab in dem komischen blog drin
gepackt das ist doch nicht weil ich auch
noch herkommen scheiße hier verfolgt
mich gar nicht okay die ursache für den
absturz ist auf jeden fall zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt zur aufnahme dieses videos
noch nicht bekannt allerdings soll es
auch nicht so krass darum wirklich gehen
sondern es soll mehr darum gehen wie
manche leute auf twitter damit
umgegangen sind und zwar normalerweise
find ich money boy haut zwar ganz cool
alliance raus manchmal so zahlt witzig
und so aber ich finde bei sowas leiten
wir witze zu machen so was wie ja
ist der unterschied zwischen germanwings
und hot wings die hot wings kommen gut
in deutschland an
das finde ich hat damit einfach nichts
zu tun natürlich ist es er hat selber
gesagt ist es meinungsfreiheit und rede
frei und künstlerische freiheit und
alles aber ich finde das geht echt zu
weit mit seinem humor dann da aber ich
möchte das jetzt nicht nur auf eine
person ihr beziehen und auf money boy
und ich möchte auch nicht dass er
deswegen jetzt gerettet wird es ist halt
wie gesagt nur meine meinung
es geht halt allgemein auch darum was
andere leute auf twitter gepostet haben
dagegen zahlt beispielsweise auch um so
sachen es war beispielsweise der letzte
tag von dem kc also kids choice award
abstimmen kampf krampf er gesagt von
david tutorial und wer dann nicht sonst
noch alles dabei ist haben halt noch mal
alle gesagt sie herkommen wurde weiter
und dann kam da ich so beiträge an die
von muscat und so weiter auch retweetet
wurden wo dann wirklich user weil sie
nicht 14 15 jahre kann man natürlich
nicht davon ausgehen dass man über alles
in der welt bescheid weiß aber so weit
sollte man differenzieren können dass
man dann nicht schreibt scheiß auf die
leute die dort umgekommen sind wir
müssen da geht's um kids choice award
boten da denke ich mir einfach nur was
ist denn los oder dann wurde da
beispielsweise auch sowas getwittert wie
ja dann wollten wir jetzt halt nicht nur
für herr tutorial sondern unter anderem
auch für die angehörigen der sache da
das abstürze oder was da war haben
einander halt leute also ich weiß was
aber so haben das halt leute getwittert
des absturzes oder was da war habe ich
alles gesehen und musste ich mir einfach
durch lesen freunde jedem server lag
grad ein bisschen deswegen lasse ich das
mal zusammen in der zweiten runde
ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht so viel
arbeit dass videos doch jetzt eigentlich
schon wieder vorbei und zwar ich mich
also ich finde dass
wenn man wenn man nicht davon bescheid
weiß und ein mann wenn man ein
gefühlloser mensch ist und man sagt es
mir doch ganz egal was da mit dem
flieger passiert ist dann soll man
wenigstens den anderen leuten die da
ihre anteilnahme zeigen denen nicht
irgendwie im weg stehen oder die die
nicht irgendwie runter machen oder so da
waren echt wirklich auch leute was soll
denn diese kcal hat nicht was eine katze
sondern was soll diese germanwings kacke
in den trends daher steckt da die oder
so muss natürlich jetzt nichts gegen
irgendwelche youtuber die da an dem kz
teilnehmen die kölner ja mehr oder
weniger nix für außer wenn wir die leute
wirklich noch angespannt haben da an dem
tag sogar weiter zu wollten habe ich
weiß beispielsweise felix hat es gut
gemacht der hat getwittert ja hier
stellt man fragen an sie und mich aber
bitte nicht mit hashtag weil germanwings
da drin bleiben soll
einfach damit die leute sich darüber
unterhalten können und nicht irgend so
ein belangloser youtuber scheiß dann da
in den trend steht das habe ich ja schon
voll oft bemängelt dass es bei twitter
dann echt einfach so ist da stehen dann
themen drin wo irgendein journalist
erhängt wurde
und dann steht da drüber ja smi oder
irgendwie sowas es geht nicht gegen die
youtuber an sich gar keine frage das
soll gegen gar keine geben nur einfach
an unsere gesellschaft mittlerweile was
dafür prioritäten sich im internet
gesetzt werden finde ich echt nicht cool
und da möchte ich euch jetzt einfach mal
so ein bisschen auffordern dann nicht
irgendwie die leute zu halten die dann
da zu germanwings verschreiben und auch
nicht jetzt ich weiß jeder der kids
choice award des voting ist beendet und
da kann ich jetzt nichts mehr zu sagen
allerdings ich hab mich einfach so
gefühlt als musste ich das mal einfach
kurz loswerden youtube ist etwas
broadcast yourself man kann einfach hoch
sein wird man will und das ist jetzt
gerade meine meinung zu dem thema ich
finde es unfassbar krass wie sich die
leute wohl ich meine da waren echt ich
weiß es selber ich war im sommer in
bulgarien und wir waren auf einer reise
mit freunden und wir haben gefeiert und
alles und dann ist man nachher
zurückgeflogen bei uns gab es auch
turbulenz weil wir mit bulgarien er
geflogen sind das jetzt nicht so die
nominierte airline von den ganzen die es
gibt und da hatten wir echt auch schon
kurz vorm kollaps aufwärts abstürzen und
ich denke einfach nur wenn die familie
wirklich wartet auf diese
diese deutsche reisegruppe da die da
irgendwie party gemacht hat oder so und
die eltern warten darauf ihre kinder und
dann verschwindet der das flugzeug vom
radar und ich weiß echt nicht war ich
echt gänsehaut also wenn ich elternteil
darf ich will das echt ich möchte da ich
nicht an
ich kann also ich möchte echt nicht
irgendwie angehöriger sind das ist ich
weiß nicht was ich da sagen soll aber
wenn ich dann wirklich sowas lese von
unwissenden leuten hell was ist denn
germanwings wir müssen kc an die trends
bringen das soll wirklich nicht gegen
die youtuber gehen oder gegen den kids
choice award da kann natürlich keiner
was für das was jetzt gerade passiert
aber ich finde da muss man dann einfach
sowas stoppen das kann echt nicht sein
und auch dann da witze drüber machen das
ist echt ganz unterste schublade ja
freunde das war's dann auch schon mit
diesem etwas ernsteren video ich weiß
sonst hier immer und ab morgen ist es
auch wieder und übermorgen und so dass
ich dann wieder hier ein bisschen so hay
group neues video aber es ist halt ein
aktuelles geschehen ist was passiert ist
und genauso wie damals bei der steckdose
sache hatte ich ja auch ein video
gemacht wo ich einfach mal meine meinung
loswerden wollte
und ich fand hier was wirklich sogar
noch viel wichtiger als wirklich auch
unsere zuschauer angeht die das da
teilweise gemacht haben
also ja freunde das video soll gegen gar
keinen gehen das soll nur ein bisschen
meine meinung zu der ganzen sache
darstellen dass ich das echt nicht cool
finde wie sowas dann quasi in den trends
dargestellt wird oder allgemein auf
twitter ich hoffe einfach nur dass ihr
jetzt wisst wie ich darüber denke dass
man eventuell dann nicht bei sowas
schreiben sollte ja pack mal hier
germanwings oder was ist aus den trends
oder sofort in die richtung
ich möchte da gar nicht mehr viel zu
sagen ich habe meine ganze meinung
gesagt und damit beende ich jetzt hier
das video ich fühle mich einfach so ein
bisschen so als müsste ich mich manchmal
einfach mitteilen auf youtube was meine
meinung dazu ist weil ich lese dann
sowas und denke mir nur so was soll das
aber ich
ja ich habe mich einfach dazu gefühlt
als müsste ich dazu ein video aufnehmen
es tut mir leid falls sich eure zeit
verschwendet habe mit meiner meinung
aber ich hoffe ich konnte den einen oder
anderen zum nachdenken bringen und
vielleicht habe ich sogar die personen
angesprochen die so etwas in die
richtung getwittert haben oder gepostet
oder gesagt oder kommentiert oder
wordpress ich bin raus tschüss